I started to feel like maybe they're
transphobic or maybe they're closeted
trans you know I feel like that's a
thing it is the thing it is totally
thing
hi my name is Christina hi I'm Skylar
and my preferred pronouns are he/him
and my pronouns are she in her I was
like mom I know you think I'm gay but
I'm not she didn't like fully understand
and then she did her own research on it
she became more accepting of it it was
better for me because it made my life
easier and happier as a person to know
that my mom was okay with it cuz my mom
means like everything to me and I was
physically and verbally assaulted I just
had people like scream awful things that
me while I was walking through the
hallway but I think once I was in
seventh grade it honestly wasn't as bad
it's just you know sixth grade is just
such a hard year anyway for everyone and
especially when you're trans and you're
trying to deal with all of these things
and trying to deal with just doing your
high school in general it is so
stressful a big part of me is being
trans and like if that means that that
person isn't going to be friends with me
then so be it because honestly I'd
rather that people know that I'm trans
and not be friends with me
then someone not know that I'm trans and
be friends with me for so long and not
know this huge part of my identity that
I'm so proud of after I transitioned my
friends were so supportive of me yeah
they don't bring up that I am
transgender and they don't bring it up
at all because it's like what is there
to bring up
yeah so I didn't want to go to the girls
restroom and then I couldn't go to the
boys restroom because everyone just
looked at me I would actually like take
my time and just walk across the campus
to go use supportive hotties
the fact that I actually wanted to go to
a port-a-potty instead of a bathroom
that was marked it's sad because they're
not clean it it's just so awful that
like I think that trans people are made
out to almost feel like be like if we're
predators or something or like like
going into the bathroom to like do
something to someone you know you're
like people should just be able to use
whatever bathroom they want to use I
mean it's a bathroom you know a teacher
that I remember in my high school her
name is um miss Marquez when all my
classmates were calling me by my other
name the one that I wanted she kind of
took note of that and she pulled me
aside one day and she's like so you want
me to call you Skyler and I'm like yes
please and then she's like you want me
to call you by male pronoun so I was
like well yes I would appreciate that
out of all the teachers I have she like
really made me feel okay about myself
you know i've dealed with awful
counselors that weren't accepting but i
mean i've also had really good
experiences my third grade teacher
before I transitioned is like never
messed my pronouns up has never messed
my name up I just wish that there were
more teachers like him because honestly
I've had I've just not had the best
teachers
if you're a trans person out there that
is watching this video right now just
want you to know that it's gonna be hard
but it's so worth it in the end when you
are able to be yourself and be able to
feel comfortable in your skin
we've been in your bath way better I
seen the men's room it's not that clean
girls restrooms are cleaner it's just
true